Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir haben schon viel zu lange nicht mehr über die Premier League gesprochen. Da gibt es so viele Themen, das holen wir jetzt nach hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit Uli Hebel. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und ich begrüße Uli Hebel von Click und Rush und natürlich von Sky und der Saunen. Hallo Uli.
Ich schließe mich an, hallo Höhrende, hallo Max.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Weißt du, wie viel die Ausgabe des Kurzpasses ist?
Es muss jetzt eine Runde sein. Oder du hast es extra für mich zur Nummer 23 werden lassen.
Nein, nein, es ist die Nummer 200, die wir gerade zusammen aufnehmen. Und da habe ich mir doch was ganz Besonderes ausgedacht, nämlich dass wir jetzt mal das nachholen, was in den letzten Wochen aus organisatorischen Gründen und Krankheitsgründen und alle möglichen Gründe kamen da zusammen nicht geklappt hat. Nämlich, dass wir mal über die Premier League sprechen. Da haben wir einen Füllhorn an Themen. Deswegen will ich gar nicht jetzt noch vorlabern, sondern fange direkt an. Uli, lass uns mal zuerst beginnen mit dem Verkauf von Chelsea. Roman Abramovic hat sich antizipierend dessen, was angesichts des Kriegs von Russland gegen die Ukraine passieren würde, von Chelsea getrennt. Es läuft jetzt schon die Biete runter an neue Käufer. Es gab harte Sanktionen, die auch Chelsea betroffen hätten. Die wurden jetzt schon ein bisschen gelockert. Also es sieht jetzt nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, nicht mehr so aus, als müsste man im Sechs-Sitzer zum nächsten Champions-League-Spiel in Madrid reisen. Wie ist denn der aktuelle Stand bei Chelsea?
Also so ähnlich, wie du es jetzt angedeutet hast. Im Moment wird sich unterhalten, sozusagen mit potenziellen Käufern. Die erste Runde ist schon leicht eingedämmt. Es waren ungefähr 200 Bieter, die angeblich sowohl solvent gewesen sein sollen, als auch Interesse gehabt haben. Das soll jetzt schon leicht eingedämmt worden sein, auf die die wirklich dann Vollzug melden können im Sinne eines Verkaufs. Das ist jetzt im Moment der Stand der Dinge, dass man da noch sondiert, was das Richtige ist. Aber, und das ist auch schon durchgesickert, Roman Abramowitsch wünscht sich in etwa, sofern er noch was wünschen darf, einen Verkaufswert von rund 3 Milliarden Pfund. Und das scheint in diese Richtung zu gehen. Ich bin nach wie vor etwas skeptisch, ob das Angebot, das aus Saudi-Arabien gekommen sein soll, von einem Konsortium, das keine Nähe haben soll zum Start. So ist es vermeldet worden vor circa eineinhalb Wochen in etwa. Und die sollen von sich aus 3,7 Milliarden geboten haben. Das halte ich allerdings bis heute für eine Nebelkerze und vielleicht sogar eher ein Move von Seiten Abramowitschs, um zu zeigen, Chelsea ist das wert, was ich möchte. Und seid lieber schnell ihr anderen, damit das Ding nicht schneller über die Ladenthek geht. Aber erstaunlicherweise, ich dachte, der Verkauf geht sehr, sehr schnell. Es gab sogar, das habe ich auch mal gelesen, eine Frist, die wäre letzten Freitag abgelaufen, dass der Verein hätte verkauft werden müssen. Und nachdem was der Liga-Chef, der Premier League, gesagt hatte, hatte ich auch damit gerechnet, dass das eine Sache von eher eineinhalb Wochen wird, als denn jetzt, wo sich das ja fast schon seit Ende Februar zieht, mehr oder weniger. Also sehr, sehr viel länger, als ich dachte.
Ja, und man muss dazu sagen, man weiß nicht alles über diesen Verkauf. Die Rain Group, das ist die Bank, die das Ganze verwaltet. Da gibt es immer mal wieder Informationen. Also angeblich sollen jetzt vier Bieter auf einer Kurzliste stehen. Angeblich soll es eine Auflage geben, dass jeder Bieter mindestens eine Milliarde Pfund in Mannschaft und Umfeld investieren muss. Also dass man nicht nur fürs Kaufen Geld zahlt, sondern auch noch sicherstellt, dass auch das, was Roman Abramovic auch gemacht hat, nämlich einfach Geld reinzupumpen, dass das weiter funktioniert. Und es soll auch die leidige Stadionsituation bei Chelsea angegangen werden. Chelsea hat ja ein viel kleineres Stadion als zum Beispiel Manchester United und plant schon seit Ewigkeiten, nachdem ich es gelesen habe, das umzubauen. Kommt aber irgendwie nicht voran. Aber lass mal kurz einen Schritt zurücktreten, bevor wir vielleicht auch kurz über die Namen sprechen, die da so in der Verlosung gerade sind für diesen Verkauf. Wie bewertest du das denn jetzt mit ein bisschen Abstand? Also dieser Krieg in der Ukraine, der hat ja ganz viele Dinge verändert, unsere Welt erschüttert, kann man so sagen. Und eben auch jetzt letztlich zu diesem Verkauf geführt, bei dem ich aber das Gefühl habe, es gibt so ein komisches Zwischending. Also gegenüber Russland positionieren sich viele Europäerinnen und Europäer sehr eindeutig. Es gibt ja auch einen klaren Aggressor in diesem Krieg. Es ist sehr klar, wer da wen angegriffen hat. In UK wird es schon ein bisschen schwieriger. Die Sanktionen auf politischer Seite sind nicht ganz so einheitlich, würde ich sagen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die auf europäischer oder US-amerikanischer Seite. Und ich habe ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das auch im Verhältnis zu Roman Abramovic der Fall ist. Und zwar nicht nur bei Chelsea-Fans. Würdest du dir da zustimmen?
Ja, das ist so. Also ich glaube, man muss sich darüber im Klaren sein. Ich hatte mir die Liste mal angesehen von Russen in UK, die sanktioniert werden. Ich glaube, 204 Namen umfassend. Da müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachschauen, da sehe ich eine Lüge. Aber der mit Abstand öffentlich bekannteste ist Roman Abramovic. Und das ist genauso gemeint, dass an ihm ein Exempel statuiert wird. Boris Johnson hat wenig andere Dinge getan in seinen nicht immer unpopulistischen Reden, als sich Roman Abramovic persönlich vorzuknöpfen. Und das ist ein Symbol, dass das Parlament permanent nach außen schicken wollte. Und insofern ist das ja gelungen. Weil ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen, die Sanktionen, die Chelsea auferlegt bekommen hat, zunächst von United Kingdom, später dann ja auch von der EU, die finde ich schon durchaus nicht undrastisch. Ich hätte auch fast gar nicht damit gerechnet, dass die so ausfallen. Das war natürlich auch da erst einmal in der Härte arg symbolisch. Es ist dann schon vieles, wie du es ja auch schon gesagt hast, wieder so leicht marginalisiert worden, aber wirklich auch nur leicht. Also es ist nach wie vor nicht so, dass beispielsweise ein Spieler seinen Vertrag verlängern dürfte. Und es gibt einige Auslaufende in dem Team. Deswegen muss ich schon sagen, einerseits kann man das als hart und Symbolpolitik verurteilen. Andererseits ist das Zeichen, was seitens des Parlaments gemacht werden sollte, durchaus angekommen. Nämlich, wer Business macht mit Chelsea, macht Business mit Roman Abramovich, macht Business mit dem Kreml. Der letzte Schritt ist vielleicht nicht so sehr zulässig. Da gab es ja auch Zweifel darüber, ob Abramovich wirklich noch Kontakte in den Kreml unterhält. Es ist inzwischen, so sagt man per Video, bewiesen, dass dem so ist. Und auch in der jüngeren Vergangenheit Abramovich sehr wohl noch Kontakt hatte zu Putin. Vormals, glaube ich, ist das bekannt und da muss man auch nicht mehr drüber diskutieren. Und trotzdem ist dieses Zeichen so, wie es da ist, eins, das ich nachvollziehen kann. Man könnte jetzt natürlich noch ausweitend darüber sprechen, ob man sich nicht in anderen Krisengebieten und mit deren Kapitalgebern auch so verhalten müsste. Aber das würde wahrscheinlich fußballerische Sportliche überschreiten.
Ja, da kommt man auch ganz schnell in Argumentationsmustereien, die dann auch wegführen vom eigentlichen Problem, auch wenn die Argumentation dennoch legitim ist. Aber ich glaube auch, dass uns das jetzt hier an dieser Stelle zu weit führt. Also zu den Sanktionen, falls ihr das nicht mitbekommen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da hat zum Beispiel ursprünglich auch dazu gehört, Chelsea durfte von einem auf den nächsten Moment keine Tickets mehr verkaufen, keinen Merchandising mehr verkaufen. Es war gar nicht klar, wie man seine Personalkosten im laufenden Monat begleichen würde. Das wurde dann gelöst und unter anderem gab es eine 20.000 Pfund Obergrenze für Auswärtsfahrten. Also mehr darf das ganze Team und der ganze Staff nicht ausgeben, um eben eine Auswärtsreise zu organisieren. Wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, wurde aber unter anderem dieser Punkt dann gelockert. Geht jetzt dann aber vielleicht auch ins Detail. Lass uns kurz über die Namen sprechen, die so kursieren. Wie gesagt, man muss es mit einer gewissen Vorsicht genießen, denn zum einen hat die Verwaltende Bank da die Hand drauf, zum anderen habe ich das Gefühl, dass aber ganz bestimmte Namen auch bewusst durchgestochen werden, denn es geht in einem offenen Bieterstreit. Bis angeblich zum 11. April sollen die alle ihre Gebote abgeben. Ja klar, lanciere ich da auch den einen oder anderen Namen, um den anderen zu zeigen, ey, ihr müsst ja jetzt schon richtig reinbuttern. Denn da sind Menschen mit dabei. Wie zum Beispiel Steven Perclutxia, der Mitinhaber von Atalanta Bergamo und von den Boston Celtics. Die Ricketts-Family, sehr beliebt unter Sportfans in UK, die die Chicago Cubs haben. Der angeblich der Schweizer Milliardär Hans-Jörg Wiss zusammen mit Jonathan Goldstein. Und insgesamt gibt es sehr, sehr viele Bieter, die schon in anderen Franchises organisiert sind, vor allem in den USA. Also neben den Boston Celtics und den Cubs, die ich schon genannt habe, gibt es auch angeblich Menschen, die mit den LA Dodgers, den Philadelphia 76ers und den Sacramento Kings verbandet sind, also auch sehr viel Expertise im Bereich des Führen eines Sportunternehmens haben. Wie nimmst du denn die Diskussion dieser Bieterrunde wahr? Das ist ja etwas, was so ganz weit weg vom deutschen Fußball ist, zum Glück.
Also du musst erst mal loswerden, sportliche Expertise und Sacramento Kings. Damit hat Viver Granadive aber absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Das kann ich dir zufällig sagen.
Das ist furchtbar. Das ist erstaunlich. Normalerweise wird ja sowas in der Öffentlichkeit auch gar nicht durchgesteckt. Wer denn da die potenziellen Interessenten sein sollen? Man hörte mal zum Beispiel von dem Netflix-Besitzer, dass er sich bei Arsenal interessiert. Man hörte von Sir Radcliffe, dem reichsten Briten, der aber schon gesagt hat, ziemlich zu Beginn, dass das Interesse an Chelsea vor zwei Jahren nicht gestimmt hatte, als schon mal hieß Abramovic Wolle verkaufen. Und es stimmt jetzt auch nicht, so hat er es gesagt. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass das immer wieder durchkommt. Ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, und das bestätigt mir, ich habe meinen sehr guten Kontakt zu Chelsea vor Ort, der wiederum ziemlich gut ist mit einigen Leuten, die hochrangig in Board sitzen. Und der hat mir auch gesagt, nichts von all dem, was gerade diskutiert wird, liegt bei denen auf dem Tisch. Sondern das ist wirklich alles öffentliche Spekulation, mehr oder weniger, sodass wir das bei uns im Podcast auch so gehalten haben, dass wir immer gesagt haben, wir reden dann darüber, wenn der Takeover wirklich klar ist. Und das ist das Gute im United Kingdom. Wenn die Übernahme sich anbahnt, dann gibt es ja den sogenannten Proper Person Check, also da wird noch mal im Hintergrund getestet, ob alles in Ordnung ist. Der ist nicht immer effizient, wie wir wissen, seit der Übernahme von Newcastle United. Wenngleich auch da, finde ich, wird jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit sehr viel Unrecht getan, der Premier League. Nicht, dass sie –sie haben sich trotzdem falsch entschieden –aber in der Art und Weise, so wie es war, haben die schon die Regularien erfüllt. Das muss man schon so sagen. Die haben halt mittels Männer oder in dem Fall eine mittels Frau eingesetzt, sodass das durchging. Aber wenn das passiert, dann ist die Übernahme wirklich als solche noch ein paar Tage entfernt davon. Und dann fangen wir auch an, wirklich darüber zu reden und mal uns anzuschauen, wo sind denn die Ströme, wo kommt das Geld her, derer, die den Verein jetzt kaufen wollen, was haben die eventuell vor, was kann man von anderen Projekten mitnehmen, um es auf Chelsea zu projizieren.
Ja, das macht ihr, glaube ich, sehr gut in eurem Podcast. Deswegen lasst dann noch mit einer allgemeinen Frage enden. Ich habe in einzelnen Kommentaren gelesen, auch durchaus von Medien, die in UK beheimatet sind, dass das vielleicht ein Wendepunkt sein könnte in der Geschichte der Premier League, dass man sich jetzt entscheiden müsse, ob man diese Struktur, die man eben der Liga auferlegt hat, dadurch, dass schon seit, ich glaube, Mitte der 80er sind die ersten Vereine zu Kapitalgesellschaften geworden. Das heißt, es ist ganz tief verwurzelt im englischen Fußball, dass du einen Verein besitzen kannst. Dass es dies jetzt ein Wendepunkt sein könnte, siehst du dafür Anzeichen?
Ja, ich hoffe es auch auf eine Weise. Es ist immer schwierig und ich finde, an der Personalie Abramović kann man das sehr, sehr gut festmachen. Weil würde man, das kann man natürlich nicht, aber würde man Roman Abramović danach bewerten, was er als sportlicher Anführer des Vereins FC Chelsea gemacht hat. Und man müsste natürlich komplett vergessen, woher er das Geld hat, was nicht zulässig ist. Aber man würde das mal tun. Und sagt, er hat jetzt nur das Geld gehabt, dann ist er wahrscheinlich sogar der Vorzeigebesitzer. Weil was der bei Chelsea gemacht hat, aus diesem Verein, der marode war, mir hat das Sepp Kneisel neulich nochmal erzählt, also ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich das Gespräch schon mit ihm geführt habe, aber da hat er mir gesagt, als er damals zu Chelsea ging, das war so genau in der Phase, als das alte Chelsea noch da war und Abramović dann übernahm, da mussten die teilweise das Vormittagstraining unterbrechen, weil sie unterhalb des Heathrows trainiert hatten und dann kamen halt die Flugzeuge und sie haben sie nicht mehr gehört. Das sind heute unvorstellbare Dinge, wenn man sich das Trainingszentrum in Corpheim anguckt. Chelsea hat eins der besten Frauenfußballprogramme europaweit. Das, glaube ich, sucht komplett seinesgleichen. Die Academy, die ja auch große Teile des aktuellen Champions League-Siegers stellt, war über Jahre hinweg national derart dominant, dass es nicht mehr schön ist. Und jetzt reden wir nur vom Sportlichen. Darüber hinaus hat Abramovic –er ist ja selbst Jude –so viel getan in Sachen Aufklärung für den Holocaust. Er hat Fangruppen verbannt. Auch nachdem es jüngere Ausschreitungen gab von Chelsea-Fans gegen Tottenham im antisemitischen Sinne, hat er sich so dermaßen klar positioniert, hat sogar ein Denkmal hingestellt an die Stamford Bridge, um für immer den Holocaust zu erinnern und zu mahnen. Das sind alles Dinge, die finde ich schon sehr gut. Das Problem ist natürlich nur, man kann halt nicht. Oder ich kann nicht und ich will auch nicht vergessen, woher das Geld kommt. Das ist genau das Problem, in dem der englische Fußball steht, rein sportlich gesehen. Immerhin guckt ihr die Liga an. Da wird es wenige Zweifler darüber geben, dass das die beste, spannendste, dynamischste –keine Ahnung, welchen Superlativ ich noch auspacken könnte –Liga dieser Welt ist, den größten Superstars. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich zunehmend auch die Stimmen, die sagen, naja gut, jetzt haben wir schon Saudi-Arabien, was soll denn als nächstes noch kommen? Welches autokratische Regime soll sich denn noch einen Verein mit der Idee des Sportswashings leisten? Und da müsste man natürlich dran gehen. Ich glaube sowieso, ich mache es noch größer. Ich glaube, dass diese ganze Zäsur, die es jetzt gibt, für den kompletten europäischen Fußball seine Folgen haben. Zumindest sollte. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das haben wird, aber sollte. Da müssen wir uns schon genau überlegen, ob das alles so sinnvoll ist. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die andere Auswahl, die ständigen Konsortien, die nichts anderes machen, als das Sportinvest. Aber möchte ich meinen Verein als Investmentteilchen sehen. Das bedeutet ja immer, dass sich jemand return of invest erwartet. Und deswegen ist auch anhand des FC Chelsea das so gut zu machen und abzulesen. Weil was man der Bramović nicht vorwerfen kann, ist, dass er Chelsea als Investment gesehen hat. Er hat es als Sportswashing-Tool gesehen, wie wir jetzt wissen, Nummer eins. Nummer zwei, für sich selbst und seinen Spaß, das ist aber so. Und Nummer drei, und das ist ihm ganz zentral wichtig gewesen, natürlich funktionieren 1 und 2 auch nicht ohne, für den sportlichen Erfolg. Der war ihm natürlich extrem wichtig. Und das ist bei den meisten investierenden Leuten mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht der Fall, sondern die würden sich gerne eines Tages irgendwann mal was da rausnehmen aus dem Verein. Newcastle ist extrem leid erprüft in dem Punkt mit dem Vorgänger Mike Ashley, der das hatte und der eigentlich nichts anderes machen wollte, als seine Sportramschkette irgendwie in dem Verein unterzubringen. Aber du merkst schon, kompliziert, ich kann dir auch keine komplette Antwort geben, das würde auch, glaube ich, meine Expertise total übersteigen. Aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass ich auch in der UK was tut, tun muss und die Diskussion ist im Gange und da bin ich jetzt erstmal glücklich drüber.
Ja, ich bin da nämlich ehrlicherweise skeptischer. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da zu zynisch geworden bin oder ob ich –und das wäre dann vielleicht der nächste Punkt, über den wir mal sprechen könnten –zu sehr noch unter dem Eindruck stehe, dieses Newcastle-Verkauf ist. Denn alles, das haben wir auch damals ja auch schon auch im Rasenfunk hier besprochen, also die Freude der Newcastle-Fans über diesen Besitzer aus Saudi-Arabien, die ja verständlicherweise sehr negativ aufgefasst wurde, die hatte aber auch unter anderem den Hintergrund, wie du es gerade besprochen hast. Da ist man auch wirklich an einen Besitzer geraten, der hat den Verein nicht nach vorne gebracht, um es jetzt mal ganz milde zu formulieren. Deswegen, also auch daher kam viele Euphorie. Aber ich sehe eben ehrlicherweise keine Einzeichen dafür, dass sich irgendetwas Größeres in der Premier League verändern sollte, denn warum sollte es doch auch? Also eigentlich kann dieser Verkauf von Chelsea, wenn er jetzt noch reibungslos über die Bühne läuft, und aktuell sieht es ja sehr danach aus, am Anfang konnte man noch vermuten, vielleicht wird das so Hoppela di Hoppe ein bisschen schwierig, aber jetzt hat man einen ordentlichen Prozess aufgesetzt. Ich denke, das wird als Erfolgsgeschichte verkauft werden. Es wird der teuerste Sportverein der Welt sein bis dato, der dann verkauft wird, der seinen Besitzer wechselt. Alles wird weiterlaufen, es wird neue Projekte geben. Deswegen sehe ich gar keine Anhaltspunkte für die Premier League da einzuhalten. Die hätte es wirklich nur gegeben bei Newcastle United, weil das ist für mich nochmal ein anderer Fall. Wir hatten es schon, dass Scheichtümer und Staaten sich engagieren im Sport. Katar bei PSG, dann hatten wir Abu Dhabi bei Manchester City. Ich würde behaupten, auch wenn man hier auch vorsichtig sein muss, nicht in Waterbautism abzugleiten, ich würde aber behaupten, dass Newcastle United mit Saudi-Arabien dann eine andere Qualität hatte. Und wenn man diese Hürde, wenn man die nicht reißt, dann ist es doch auch, also warum soll sich dann noch irgendetwas verändern? Oder bin ich da jetzt zu pessimistisch?
Nein, deine Argumentation ist schon richtig und nachvollziehbar. Ich glaube schon auch, dass letztlich das Sportliche ganz viel überlagert. Und ich habe ja nun mal dann auch beruflich viel mit England zu tun. Und spreche ja durchaus auch, so versuche ich es wenigstens, vor jedem Spiel mit einem Anhänger oder Anhängerin von jeweils der Mannschaft. Und das tue ich in England genauso wie in Deutschland. Und wenn ich mit denen spreche, dann kriege ich in England noch deutlicher als in Deutschland das Zeichen. Lass uns das doch bitte trennen, wo das Geld herkommt. Aber das geht nicht. Aber so ist der Engländer fußballerisch sozialisiert. Solange sportlich alles stimmt, machen sie gerne beim Rest die Augen zu. Insofern kann ich das schon nachvollziehen. Und solange die Liga so attraktiv ist, wie sie ist, gibt es wenige, die ernsthaft hinterfragen, warum sie denn so attraktiv ist. Und insofern, ja, ich kann das schon nachvollziehen, dass du pessimistisch bist, aber ich bin schon mal, ich bin jetzt erstmal glücklich, dass die Diskussion so entbrannt ist, stärker, erstaunlicherweise, jetzt als sie bei Newcastle seinerzeit geführt worden ist, jetzt in diesem ganzen Chelsea-Konstrukt. Und darüber bin ich schon mal glücklich. Und in dem Fall ist vielleicht der Populismus der Regierung manchmal auch gar nicht so schlecht, weil er zumindest dafür sorgt, dass das jetzt tagelang dominant war. Auch für alle, die nicht wollten, dass man Sport und, wie sie es nennen, Politik vermischt. Das dominante Thema, 14 Tage, vielleicht sogar länger, drei Wochen, auch auf sämtlichen Sport-Only-Seiten, war ausschließlich Chelsea, die Sanktionen, der Krieg, Geldmachenschaften und dergleichen. Und das ist jetzt erstmal das, was ich begrüße. Ob ich jetzt so weit gehen würde, dass ich sage, dass deshalb Newcastle ebenfalls zum Verkauf gezwungen wird? Nein. Würde ich denken, dass sowas in Zukunft nicht mehr passiert? Nein. Aber ich hoffe zumindest, dass die Hemmschwellen etwas alarmierter sind.
Ja, gut, stimmt. Also nach vorne gerichtet könnte das eben eine Auswirkung haben. Da muss man auch aufpassen, nicht unfair zu werden bzw. zu oberflächlich zu sein. Also hätten wir vor einem Jahr eine Umfrage gestartet, wer ist der am kritischsten zu bewertende Investor in der Premier League, dann wäre bestimmt nicht Roman Abramovic auf Platz 1 rausgekommen. Niemand von uns, oder zumindest viele von uns, hätten das nicht erwartet, wie sich das alles entwickelt. Und ich finde, das kann man dann auch vereinen und entscheiden, nicht zum Vorteil machen, das bringt uns alle nicht weiter.
Hattest du im Ernst nach dem Champions-League-Sieg auch nur eine Zeile darüber gelesen?
Nein, eben nicht. Genau. Es war eher –Gar nicht. Ich meine, das war ja schon damals 2012 so, dass es eher so das Ziel einer langen Reise war, die quasi mit ihrem eigenen tragischen Höhepunkt von John Terry, der ausrutschte beim Elfmeter in Moskau gegen Manchester United im Finale. Und das war ja quasi die Positivgeschichte, zu der in den deutschen Medien erzählt, Negativgeschichte zur Niederlage des FC Bayern, dass Chelsea da eben endlich seinen Champions-League-Titel bekommen hat und dass auch Roman Abramovic endlich seinen Champions-League-Titel bekommen hat. Das ist eben –genau, das ist das, was ich meine. Und dennoch haben wir jetzt aber –zumindest eventuell könnte es jetzt sein, dass diese rote Linie Saudi-Arabien –anders als in der Formel 1 –nicht mehr überschritten wurde, zumindest beim Chelsea-Verkauf. Dann lasst man noch bei Newcastle United bleiben. Sportlich gesehen hat sich das jetzt wieder beruhigt. Man ist der Abschiebszone entflohen, man hat jetzt 31 Punkte, 9 Punkte Vorsprung auf Watford. Das sieht alles sehr gesettelt aus. Wie hat sich denn deiner Meinung nach die Diskussion rund um Newcastle United verändert in den letzten Monaten? Ist es noch so kritisch wie damals bei der Übernahme?
Gar nicht, im Gegenteil. Da wird es dann richtig hässlich. Es gab ja jüngstes Aufeinandertreffen von Newcastle und Chelsea, ich glaube vor 14 Tagen in etwa. Das ist ja, wenn wir so wollen, das Original-Sportswashing-Projekt gegen das jüngste und wahrscheinlich sogar öffentlichste. Das war jetzt schwierig, dass das am meisten öffentlich diskutierte. Im Vorfeld, das hat es, glaube ich, ganz gut abgebildet, und im Vorfeld dieser Partie hat ein Journalist, der öfter dabei ist und sich durchaus auch schwierige Themen annimmt, einen Monolog vor einer Frage an Thomas Duchel, der ja alles erklären muss im Moment. Muss ja auch so sein, weil es darf ja gar keiner andere sprechen bei Jesse, hat die Frage gestellt, ob man denn jetzt mit Blick darauf schon sagen kann, naja, Newcastle ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm. Und daran sieht man, dass das voll funktioniert hat. Die lehnen sich im Moment einfach zurück in Newcastle und denken sich, je länger das geht mit Jesse und je mehr da eine Sau durchs Durch getrieben wird. Und dann wird ja nicht ganz oft sachlich diskutiert, sondern da werden ja ganz viele Dinge demonisiert. Und dann gibt es diese eine Richtung, in die das geht. Und dann wird das verteufelt und dann wird nur noch auf Chelsea rumgehackt. Und plötzlich, peu à peu, wird Newcastle so zu einem, ja mein Gott, naja gut, wir führen ja wenigstens keinen Krieg. Also ist natürlich auch nur die halbe Wahrheit, aber…
Ich nenne es den Hoffenheim-Effekt. Mit dem Moment, in dem Leipzig in die Bundesliga kam, gab es ein in Anführungszeichen größeres Übel.
Ja, genau, ganz genau. Das könnte man jetzt auch auf weltpolitisch… Das kannst du in der Rassismusforschung auch immer noch mal sehen. In dem Moment, wo der ganze IS-Start gekommen ist, hatten es die dunkelhäutigen Menschen nicht mehr so schwierig. Also jetzt mal ganz salopp formuliert. Ich möchte es jetzt nicht zu groß machen. So bananen das klingt, aber so ist das. In dem Fall, dass Newcastle fast davonkommt im Moment und sich einfach nur denkt, ja gut, läuft ja. Solange das Regime sich da jetzt erstmal zurückhält, das tun sie. Die sportlichen Schlagzeilen dominieren insofern, wenigstens regional bei Newcastle, dass sie aus dem Gröbsten raus sind. Das heißt, erste Erfolge im Sportswashing stellen sich ein.
Es wird auch immer funktionieren, Sportswashing. Weil Sport ist etwas, das wir für Eskapismus nutzen. Wir gucken ja nicht Sport, weil wir sagen, so jetzt wollen wir uns aber hier mal richtig noch mal kognitiv mit etwas auseinandersetzen. Sondern wir gucken es ja aus anderen Gründen, zumindest viele von uns. Du jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anders als der Rest der Welt. Du wirst da immer kognitiv mitdenken und analysieren. Es ist ja auch dein Beruf. Aber allein deshalb wird immer das sportliche Abschneiden über alles seinen Schatten und aber auch seinen Lichtstrahl so werfen, dass andere Dinge dann dagegen ausnivelliert werden. Ich glaube, das ist eine Tatsache.
Es macht es auch schwierig, weil gerade jetzt auch bei Newcastle oder auch bei Chess ist es genau das Gleiche. Ich bin ja, wenn ich kommentiere, zum Beispiel auch den Hörerinnen und Hörern oder Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auch verpflichtet. Ich kann ja nicht, ich versuche das immer unterzubringen. Und ich glaube auch, dass diese Überforderung durchaus auch wichtig ist und dass die das letztlich auch wollen. Nur ich kann jetzt nicht bei jedem Tor beispielsweise von Newcastle sagen, das Tor war gut, das hat der 30-Millionen-Mann erzielt, den sie normalerweise hätten aber nicht kaufen dürfen. Weil an diesem Geld, mit dem sie ihn bezahlt haben, klebt Blut. Dann wird es schwierig. Wann mache ich es, wann mache ich es nicht? Also das ist nicht so leicht, finde ich, da einen guten Weg zu finden. Da gibt es auch des öfteren Diskussionen, Streit auch in sozialen Medien. Und bei Twitter kann man das schon gar nicht diskutieren mit den wenigen vorrätigen Zeichen. Aber das ist immer ganz, ganz schwierig. Wann sage ich wo, wie, in welcher Deutlichkeit und wie oft, damit ich nicht alle langweile und nerfe. Weil oft sind sie ja dann doch nur des Fußballs wegen da. Und das muss ich, insbesondere jetzt, wo ich im PayTV arbeite, als Sammelbegriff, muss ich das dann auch respektieren.
Ach ja, eine der vielen Ambivalenzen, die wir heutzutage auszuhalten haben. Sicherlich aber nicht die schlimmste. Dann lasst uns Newcastle an der Stelle zumachen. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt jetzt gar keinen Bock mehr über das Sportliche zu reden. Ich finde die wichtigen Dinge zu Newcastle, haben wir gesagt. Worüber wir erschreckend wenig gesprochen haben, bis fast gar nicht bisher im Rasenfunk, war Ralf Rangnick bei Manchester United. Darüber würde ich gerne als nächstes bei dir sprechen. Jetzt switchen wir thematisch jetzt aber doch ins Sportliche hinein. Ich gucke mir einfach mal die aktuelle Tabelle an. Die aktuelle nach 29, beziehungsweise manche Mannschaften haben auch 30 Spiele. Ein paar auch noch 27. Es ist ein bisschen zerfleddert in der Premier League. Aber 29 ist so die Top-Spitzengruppe, da haben die meisten 29 Spiele. Da liegt Manchester United auf Rang 6 mit 50 Punkten, hat 1 Punkt Rückstand auf Tottenham auf 5, hat 4 Punkte Rückstand auf die Champions League Plätze und ist in der Champions League nicht so wirklich gut weitergekommen. Man hat sich gegen Atletico ein 0 zu 1 eingehandelt, in typischer Atletico-Manier, wo man dann auch positive Dinge über United zeigen kann, aber am Ende steht eben dann, dass man, ich glaube, jetzt das fünfte Jahr in Folge keinen Titel wird gewinnen können, wenn wir mal ein Wunder in der Premier League ausschließen. Und das ist ja für United, so wie wir es in den 90er Jahren Sozialisierten kennengelernt haben, völlig untypisch. Was hat denn das Ganze mit Ralf Rangnick zu tun und wie bewertest du die Situation dort?
Es ist auch ganz, ganz schwierig. Auch da der kleine Disclaimer, insofern ist doch noch ein Anschluss zum vorherigen Thema Besutzer- schaft, ist fürchterlich. Der Verein ist inzwischen derart chaotisch geführt, wie man es sich für United gar nicht vorstellen konnte. Rangnick ist nur das allerletzte Teilchen in diesem Komplett-Collaps, den es da gibt. Die Mannschaft spielt gerade nicht gut. Das hat man gegen Atletico gesehen. Man erkennt immer so 40, 45 Minuten lang und nicht immer am Stück, was Rangnick will und wollte. Man erkennt dann aber auch, dass die Mannschaft einfach nicht so konstituiert ist, dass sie diesen Plan durchziehen können. Das heißt, es gibt teilweise Aufflackern, es gibt aber dann ganz oft, und das liegt vor allen Dingen daran, dass wenn irgendwas nicht läuft im Spiel, dann sieht man ganz, ganz oft, dass die Truppe nicht damit klarkommt. Also sprich, die sind überhaupt nicht mit Rückschlägen vertraut inzwischen und können damit gar nicht umgehen. Und das ist das Problem, dass man ganz oft in einem Spiel ganz unterschiedliches Manchester United zieht. Der Kader aber trotzdem kostet so viel, dass sie eigentlich ein Minimum auf drei sein müssten, wenn nicht sogar höher, und das ist ja auch das erklärte Ziel. Das Problem ist dann aber wiederum, dass der Verein so blauäugig in diese Saison gegangen ist und allen Ernstes nicht die Zeichen der letzten drei Jahre gesehen hat, nämlich dass sich unter Ole Gunnar Sorscher gar nichts tut. Du erinnerst dich, da haben wir ja auch schon, weiß nicht wie oft, drüber gesprochen. Da habe ich immer mal wieder anklingen lassen, dass ich nicht denke, dass Ole Gunnar Sorscher die Lösung ist. Ich sollte Recht behalten. Ich hätte es mir nicht gewünscht für ihn, aber es ist so. Und der Verein ist tatsächlich in diese Saison gewankt, ohne darüber nachzudenken, was eigentlich, wenn es nicht läuft. Und es ist nicht gelaufen. Und dann haben sie gezeigt, wie stümperhaft sie sind, haben dann immerhin Ralf Rangnick ausgegraben, dümpeln aber jetzt auch schon wieder seit drei Monaten rum, einen neuen Trainer zu installieren. Indes weiß Ralf Rangnick noch nicht mal genau, wie dieser Posten aussehen wird, den er in beratender Funktion nach der Saison haben soll und ob er überhaupt helfen soll, den neuen Trainer auszuwählen. Da ist natürlich auch einiges an Vertrauen flötig gegangen, weil die dachten, sie holen sich den deutschen Marcelo Bielsa und gehen jetzt nochmal an Chelsea ran Richtung Platz 3. So ist es auch nicht gekommen. Dafür hat dieses Team viel zu sehr strukturelle Probleme und ist taktisch derart verwahrlos gewesen, dass Rangnick gar nichts machen kann. Das macht die Gesamtgemengelage da echt unangenehm. Dann gibt es noch ein paar einzelne Spieler, die schwierig sind im Haushalt. Das macht es dann für Rangnick auch wahnsinnig frustrierend. Ich bin immer mal wieder in Kontakt mit ihm und seinem Team. Ich glaube, der hatte schon einfache Aufgaben. Es war ihm klar, aber es ist noch komplizierter geworden, als er sich dessen vorher bewusst war.
Gibt es noch eine Realität in diesem Universum, also nicht in irgendeinem Paralleluniversum, in der Ralf Rangnick Trainer bleibt bei United?
Das kann ich mir schwer vorstellen. Wenn sie jetzt gar nicht weitermachen und wirklich gar nicht ihre Leute kriegen würden, dann gäbe es das, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit würde ich bei irgendwo zwei, drei Prozent ansiedeln. Ich kann es mir schwer vorstellen. Er hat keine Akzeptanz im Umfeld bei den Legenden, die bei United durchaus immer eine Rolle spielen und die sich ja schon lautstark die ganze Zeit gegen ihn aussprechen. In der Mannschaft ist es so-so. Es gibt welche, die finden ihn ganz gut. Es gibt welche, und das sind die traditionell etwas mächtigeren, die eher denken, es müsste jemand anders sein. Und der Verein als solcher denkt sowieso, dass sie einen ganz, ganz großen Namen brauchen. Und die suchen ja immer noch bonierterweise den neuen Sir Alex Ferguson. Das heißt, ich kann mir das schwer vorstellen, dass sie mit Ralf Rangnick in den 60ern jetzt noch mal mittelfristig gehen. Vielleicht wäre das aber auch gar nicht das Richtige, das muss man so ehrlich sagen. Der würde das jetzt noch ein Jahr machen und dann würdest du ja nur noch Zeit gewinnen. Und das ist ja sowieso schon total unwürdig gewesen. Das hatte ich jetzt mal unabhängig von der Inamtsname Rangnicks, die ich nachvollziehen konnte und die ich auch gut fand und die auch bis zu gewissen Punkten funktioniert aus meiner Sicht. Aber darüber hinaus habe ich das nicht verstanden, dass United einen Interimstrainer nimmt. Wo genau wollen die hin? Und das hat ja auch an sich das Zeichen gesendet, die Saison 21, 22 ist uns egal, ob sie es wollten oder nicht. Und das ist genau gar nicht, was Manchester United tun würde in der Regel. Aber dieser Verein, du hast es ja auch eingeleitet, so wie wir ihn kennen, da müssen wir uns verabschieden. Das ist er nicht mehr. Das ist inzwischen ein Kapitalmonstrom, ja, aber nicht mehr der Verein.
Ja, das ist schon irre. Und dabei vergisst man ja auch, dass ja auch Sir Alex Ferguson nicht hochdekoriert zu United kam. Kam er nicht direkt von Aberdeen? Da hat er zwar, glaube ich, Europapokal gewonnen und schottische Meisterschaften. Aber ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass vor allem die ersten zwei Spielzeiten von ihm nicht so erfolgreich waren bei United. Ich glaube, sehr altes Team übernommen, dann aussortiert. Und dann erst wurde es zu dem United, wie wir es dann kennengelernt haben. Habe ich das so richtig?
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Ging sogar noch ein bisschen länger. Der war in den ersten drei Jahren, weiß ich nicht, wie oft schon vor dem Rauswurf. Andere Zeiten, andere Führungsebene bei United, die weniger abhängig sind von dem, was ergebnistechnisch passiert. Also die Maxime bei United heißt zwangsweise Champions League. Also wenn sie sich drohen, nicht für die Champions League zu qualifizieren, drohen sie Gelder nicht zu bekommen. Also jetzt gar nicht so sehr die Antrittsgelder, sondern vor allen Dingen im internationalen Raum die Vormachtstellung zu verlieren, weil sie einfach nicht gut genug sind. Und dann verlieben sich halt junge Menschen in Liverpool, Chelsea, City oder Real Madrid oder wer auch immer die Champions League gewinnen möchte. Und deshalb hat United für sich –und das interpretiere ich nicht, sondern das ist vor zweieinhalb Jahren oder drei Jahren in einem Investor-Call gefallen vom jetzt geschiedenen Chief Executive Ed Woodward. Da hat er gesagt, solange wir in der Champions League spielen, ist alles fein. Wenn nicht, dann werden die richtig planlos aktivistisch. Und das erleben wir jetzt eigentlich gerade bei Rangnick das zweite Mal, dass sie völlig planlos und willenlos umherirren. Was gar nicht geht für so einen Verein dieser Stärke, aber es ist de facto so. Und das habe ich mir auch nochmal von innen bestätigen lassen. Also nicht von Rangnick selbst, aber von Teilen des Sports, dass das wirklich noch chaotischer ist, als man das von außen wahrnimmt. Und gar nicht genau weiß, wer welche Rolle hat. Die haben ja jetzt einen Director of Football installiert. Ich habe in meinem Jugendlichen Leichtsinn erzählt, dass wenn das mal passiert, dann ist das Größte vorbei, dass es wenigstens eine sportliche Struktur gibt. Dieser Mensch weiß noch gar nicht, was er zu tun hat. Dann gibt es noch einen technischen Direktor, der zwischen Co-Trainer und Sportdirektor ein paar Aufgaben übernimmt, aber auch nicht richtig. Das zieht sich noch weiter bis in die Executive-Positionen rein. Das ist natürlich so gar nicht darstellbar für einen Verein dieser Größe.
Es ist durchaus bemerkenswert, wenn man sich die Premier League wenn man jetzt das größere Fenster aufzieht, dann sieht man das so ab Mitte der 2000er Jahre, also so ab 2004, 2005, dann ging das richtig los, dass im Grunde das Champions-League-Halbfinale manchmal fast komplett, also 2007, 2008 war nur Barca noch mit drin. Ansonsten waren das nur Premier League-Vereine, also die Dominanz Englands, die es schon mal Ende der 70er gab, dann durch die Heißel-Katastrophe natürlich unterbrochen wurde, dann hat sich Italien an diese Stelle gesetzt, die 90er waren dann ein lustiges Jahrzehnt, da durften viele Mal, also Roterstein-Belgrad, genauso wie Ajax Amsterdam, genauso wie AC Milan, und dann zu den 2000er mit den großen Geldverträgen, die eben noch mal andere Dimensionen hatten als der Vorsprung, den die Premier League eh schon immer hatte. Dann begann eigentlich die englische Dominanz. Und im Grunde leben wir auch noch in diesen Zeiten. Da muss man sich jetzt ja nur aktuell angucken, wer wo spielt. Ich habe aber den Eindruck, dass Manchester United den letzten Schritt, den die Premier League gegangen ist, verpasst hat, nämlich wenn ich mir angucke, was ist bei Liverpool passiert, was ist bei Manchester City passiert, was ist auch bei Chelsea passiert, dann war das, dass man nicht nur die besten Spieler hatte, sondern dass man auch das beste Funktionsteam hatte, also gute Trainer, gute Scouting, gute Ernährungswissenschaftler und so weiter und so fort. Kann es sein, dass Manchester United einfach in der Zeit stehen geblieben ist und deswegen überholt wurde?
Ja, das ist die Hypothek aus der ganzen Sir Alex Ferguson Zeit, der natürlich alles auf seine traditionelle Weise Ende 80er, Anfang 90er gelöst hat. Er konnte das alles so bedienen, hat aber ein Feld übergeben, dass nur er so bedienen konnte. Das heißt, seinerzeit, das darf man auch nie vergessen, ist in David Gill der Chief Executive gegangen, der den Verein ebenfalls sehr, sehr gut im Griff hatte. Und dann kamen eben mit Richard Arnold und David Moyes zwei, das ist natürlich völlig unzulässig, nur die zwei zu nennen, aber zwei, die den Laden schmeißen mussten, und die kamen gar nicht damit klar. Und ja, das ist schon so, dass es auch zum großen Teil daran lag. Und man muss schon auch sagen, dass United sich entwickelt hat, auch unter Solskjaer. Das möchte ich nicht wegwischen, das ist schon so. Nur andere entwickeln sich schneller, besser und progressiver. Und das ist eben der große Unterschied, dass an anderen Orten auch schneller verworfen wird, wenn etwas nicht funktioniert. Serie Arsenal, das hat jetzt drei, vier Jahre lang zur totalen Dürre geführt, aber im Moment sieht es so aus, ja, wir sind wieder auf dem richtigen Weg. Und Ateta hat einfach fünf, sechs verschiedene Dinge da probiert, rein personell auch und so weiter. Jetzt scheinen sie den Weg gefunden zu haben, der für sie funktioniert. Und das fiese für United ist, von unten drängt ein Club wie Aston Villa aus der zweitgrößten City, also City, Stadt in England, die auch investieren wollen, die sich mit 7Jarad jemanden geholt haben und die ein Konsortium hinten dran haben, die mit den Milwaukee Bucks verflochten sind. Also da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema. Die meinen es ernst und die haben Know-how, wie es ist, eine Franchise oder in dem Fall einen Verein zu führen. Und die machen ein paar ganz gute, clevere Dinge. Newcastle United mit den Geldgebern und mit diesen schier endlos gefüllten Taschen, die werden auch von hinten drängen. Also United sollte sich jetzt strategisch schon relativ schnell klar werden, wo wollen sie hin, wie wollen sie das machen, und dann sollten sie auch mal dabei bleiben und nicht dann irgendwann wieder kehrt machen. Das liegt nicht, dass sie ein weiteres Mal die Entwicklung überholt. Das einzige Department, in dem sie keine Fehler gemacht haben, war das Marketing-Department. Aber im Rest sind sie einfach im Vergleich zu anderen Vereinen, haben die Europäisierung auch verpasst, sich entsprechend so aufzustellen, dass sie mit Sportdirektoren und Co. wirklich konkurrenzfähig sind.
Manchester United ist wirklich ein ganz hervorragendes Fallbeispiel, wenn man auch darüber sprechen möchte, wie sich im Bestfall –aus Sicht des Vereins –Merchandising-Erfolg und Marketing-Erfolg, Sponsoren-Erfolg, vom sportlichen Erfolg entkoppeln kann. Im Grunde sind sie ja seit mehreren Jahren nicht mehr der attraktivste englische Verein. In den Zahlen sieht man das immer noch nicht, aber auch das römische Reich war irgendwann in viele kleine Teile zerfallen. Das kann schon auch so einem Verein passieren. Ich finde, das hast du sehr gut skizziert mit dem, was da ja um United herum passiert. Du hast einen Namen genannt, da habe ich schon gezuckt und dachte mir, da hat er mir jetzt wieder die nächste Überleitung gebaut, nämlich Arsenal. Arsenal ist bisher immer relativ zu kurz gekommen in den Kurzpassen, die wir so gemacht haben. Was, glaube ich, damit zu begründen ist, dass Arsenal oft nicht Fisch, nicht Fleisch war. Und da spreche ich jetzt, glaube ich, über einen Zeitraum von zwei, drei Jahren vielleicht sogar schon. Jetzt allerdings hat man sich in die Champions League-Ränge hineingespielt und auch eine sehr, sehr erfolgreiche Zeit hinter sich. Nachdem es zwischenzeitlich gar nicht so gut lief, man in verschiedenen Wettbewerben mehrere Niederlagen hat, gab es jetzt aus den letzten sieben Spielen sechs Siege. Was waren denn die Stellschrauben von Arteta, die er da verstellt hat, die du angesprochen hast?
Vor allen Dingen personeller Art. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal als ich hier bei dir war, haben wir gesprochen zur ersten Länderspielpause Ende September. Vielleicht war ich auch dazwischen nochmal…
9. November und am 19. Ach ne, das war Yogi. Also Ende August und Anfang November.
Ok, Ende August. Erste Länderspielpause. Da haben wir über Arsenal ganz kurz gesprochen am Ende. Da waren sie dabei den Letzten und haben, glaube ich, noch kein Tor geschossen und unzählige mehr kassiert.
Ich zitiere dich aus dieser Sendung. Körperliches Grundniveau sei erschreckend, hast du gesagt.
Da stehe ich auch noch dazu. Auch wenn es schlecht gealtert ist, muss ich sagen. Was seither passiert ist, ist ganz erstaunlich, dass Arteta in dieser Länderspielpause sich seinen Kader nochmal ganz genau angesehen haben muss. Er ist vorher einen Weg gegangen, immer mit erfahrenen Spielern zu spielen und sich gedacht, er kann einen minimalistischen Fußball da einbauen, der ihm die Ergebnisse bringt. Das hat monatelang funktioniert. Dann hat es ein paar Monate lang wieder überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Dann hat es monatelang wieder okay funktioniert. Sodass ich auch immer nicht genau wusste, ist er die Lösung, ist er das Problem, ist er die Lösung, ist er das Problem. In dieser Länderspielpause muss er derart klar für sich gesagt haben, okay, so funktioniert es nicht. Sie haben dann ja auch nochmal ordentlich investiert und haben, das ist sehr auffällig, junge Spieler geholt, die Potenzial haben. Er spielt inzwischen fast ausschließlich mit diesen jungen Spielern. Lacazette ist jetzt der Kapitän nach dem Abgang Aubameyangs, den hat er einfach gekattet, klipp und klar gesagt, nö, das ist zu alt, ist zu teuer, den will ich hier nicht mehr. Dass der nicht so alt ist, merken wir jetzt auch gerade, aber so hat er es gemacht. Lacazettes Vertrag ist immer noch nicht verlängert. Das ist der einzig übrig gebliebene alte, auf den er noch komplett setzt. Vielleicht kann man auch noch Garni Tschaka mit reinnehmen. Und ansonsten lässt er jetzt Fußball spielen mit ganz vielen jungen Leuten. Und das ist im Moment diese Dynamik, die Arsenal aufgenommen hat, die total Spaß macht. Es gibt kaum ein Team, das sich mehr lohnt, anzugucken als Arsenal im Moment. Wenn Saka, Ödegard loslegen, Fußball zu spielen, Emile Smith-Rowe, das macht einen solchen Spaß, den zuzusehen, weil die sich wirklich einfach so von Spiel zu Spiel spielen. Und das Gute ist, dass die Erwartungshaltung in den letzten drei, vier Jahren so korrigiert worden ist, dass bei Arsenal alle einfach nur sich freuen, dass sie wieder in Richtung Champions League-Qualifikation gehen und noch genießen, dass sie wieder eins der attraktivsten Teams des Landes stellen. Und das ist das Schöne an diesem Prozess. Ateta hat einmal voll umgedacht von, ich gehe minimalistisch mit Alten auf, wir spielen jetzt fast überschwänglichen Fußball mit Jungen und scheint sich bestätigt zu fühlen. Und so geht jetzt das Transfergebaren weiter. Ist aber ehrlicherweise stark von einem Trainer, der ja auch im Job gelernt hat, das ist sein Erster, dass der sich so hat anpassen können und keine Angst hatte, sein Gesicht zu verlieren. Das rechne ich ihm sehr, sehr hoch an.
Und ist ja auch etwas, was man wirklich nicht so häufig sieht. 40 Jahre ist Michael Ateta jung, um das kurz einzuordnen. Er selbst gehört ja zu einer sehr jungen Generation von Trainern. Ist das dann näher dran an dem, wie Arsene Wenger auch früher Arsene revolutioniert hat? Also wenn du sagst, junge, talentierte Spieler, dann klingt das nach Wenger. Wenn du jetzt allerdings sagst, sehr schön anzusehender, dynamischer Fußball, dann schon nicht mehr so sehr. Und vielleicht darf man ja auch gar nicht immer den Fehler machen, dass man immer alles auf Wenger zurückbezieht bei Arsene, nur weil er eben da so lange war. Aber ist das ein Vergleich, der deiner Meinung nach überhaupt noch eine Rolle spielt bei diesem Arsene?
Der spielt immer eine Rolle. Und Wenger sorgt auch dafür mit öffentlichen Äußerungen, dass es für immer eine Rolle spielen wird.
Friedhelm Funkel des internationalen Weltfußballs.
Eigentlich muss man aufhören, weil besser wird es nicht mehr. Das ist der treffende Vergleich, ganz genau. Der auch übrigens zu jedem und allem was weiß. Es ist schon zulässig, das zu vergleichen, auf einer Weise, weil beide auf ihre Art und Weise revolutioniert haben. Nur hat Arteta das sehr viel weniger im Alleingang gemacht als Wenger. Es waren aber auch andere Zeiten, möchte ich Wenger gar nicht vorwerfen. Logischerweise muss Arteta sich sehr viel mehr den aktuellen Gegebenheiten anpassen. Er ist nicht so sehr ein Vordenker, wie es Wenger seiner Zeit war, als der Arsenal übernahm und eine Idee hatte vom Fußball, die bis dato in England einfach nicht bekannt war. Arteta macht das schon mit vorrätigen Mitteln. Der hat sich sehr stark angeguckt bei Guardiola, der unter anderem einzelne Aspekte des Spiels rausgegriffen. Das ging schon unter Emery los, dass Arsenal endlich so etwas hatte wie Pressing im System. Das war ja unter Wenger einfach nicht da. Die waren ja fußballerisch einfach in 1995 hängen geblieben. Das hat eine Zeit lang sehr, sehr gut funktioniert, aber es war halt nicht mehr state of the art und damit waren sie auch fast gar nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig auf dem Niveau. Das hat bei Arteta schon sehr viel pragmatischer, und weniger romantisch als Wenger. Aber grundsätzlich die Bewegung als solche innerhalb des Vereins und ich habe so auch das Gefühl, in etwa die Stimmung, die seinerzeit unter Wenger erzeugt worden, ist es jetzt schon auch die gleiche. Weil, wann immer ich mich mit Arsenal-Fans unterhalte, die sind ja in Deutschland auch wirklich da, anhand dieser Zeiten ist da wirklich eine große Fanbase erstellt worden, dann merkt man, die haben endlich wieder Freude dran. Das war jahrelang so, dass sie ihm in den Podcast-Fragen reingeschickt haben, und jetzt ist es endlich wieder so, na, schaffen wir Champions League? Und wie gut ist eigentlich Saka? Und Ödigard ist toll. Und wen können wir noch verpflichten, dass es besser wird? Da ist irgendwie etwas entfacht worden. Das genieße ich auch gerade sehr. Das ist immer schön, wenn ich die im Dienstplan lese.
Ja, das geht mir ganz genauso. Ich kenne auch ein paar Arsenal-Fans. Früher war das so, dass ich immer daran gesehen habe, dass Arsenal spielt, dass irgendjemand von ihnen geschrieben hat, da geht es schon wieder los. Dann haben sie entweder schon das 0 zu 1 kassiert oder standen kurz davor, weil sie wieder nicht gut waren und dann war das Spiel verloren, war Arsenal nicht die Mannschaft, die zurückgekommen ist. Und jetzt lese ich da andere Tweets. Da kann ich auch nicht so neutral sein, dass ich mich da nicht mit den Leuten mit freue. Ganz liebe Grüße zum Beispiel an den Midis Polis, falls ihr das hier hört. Freue ich mich immer, wenn ich das lese. Wir haben es ja schon gemerkt, indirekt, ich führe immer so ein bisschen Buch, was wir eigentlich schon so angesprochen haben im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Und da habe ich notiert beim letzten Kurzpass, in dem die Premier League vorkam, am 18. Januar, dass damals Hendrik gesagt hat, Hendrik Buch heißt er, und das soll jetzt aber kein Shaming werden, definitiv nicht. Aber er hat damals gesagt, dass die Meisterschaft entschieden sei, denn Manchester City war mit elf Punkten vorne. Und sie hatten keinerlei Aussetzer, sie hatten zu diesem Zeitpunkt zwölf Spiele in Folge gewonnen, trotz Corona-Auswählen, trotz Verletzungen. Ich glaube, wir alle dachten damals, dass Manchester City sicher Meister wäre. Jetzt gucke ich auf die Tabelle, lieber Uli, und ich sehe ein Pünktchen. Ein Pünktchen zwischen Manchester und Liverpool. Was ist da bei diesen beiden Vereinen passiert? Warum gibt es jetzt wieder Meisterschafts-Rennen?
Ja, es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und jetzt gibt es ja dann Anfang April das Duell, auf das ich mich einfach nur freue, weil das wird wieder sensationell, das ist ja die Rivalität der letzten Jahre in der Premier League. Ganz kurz zusammengefasst, Manchester City hat sich zwei menschliche Wochenenden geleistet und Liverpool roboterhafte Wochen. Das ist erstaunlich, was Liverpool gerade wieder tut. Es ist sowieso noch viel erstaunlicher, wenn man sich überlegt, woher die kommen aus dieser Krisensaison, das war ja wirklich eine Krisensaison. Das ist ja nicht übertrieben oder boulevardisiert, sondern das war ja wirklich so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, oh, hier kracht alles zusammen mit den vielen Verletzten der Innenverteidigung und dann diesen Heimspielwochen, die es ja nie gab unter Glob, in dem sie plötzlich alles automatisch verloren hatten. Nichts davon ist übrig geblieben. Im Gegenteil, es ist sogar fast eine Trotzbewegung daraus geworden. Und die ist jetzt wieder an einer Phase angekommen, in der Liverpool mich sehr stark an das Team erinnert, dass sie vor circa zwei Jahren waren. Das war ja dann die Pandemie unterbrochene Saison, in der sie dann haben Meister werden können. Und da haben sie es fast zu Kunstform erhoben, ein Spiel zu Ende zu managen. Und das war noch das Problem am Anfang der Saison, dass sie teilweise geprast haben, dass sie dann zwar zwei Tore gemacht haben, aber dann auch noch zwei kassiert haben manchmal. Und ein dummes Unentschieden, sich haben abbringen lassen, gibt es nicht mehr. Die gewinnen wie selbstverständlich gerade all diese Spiele wieder. Teilweise tun sie es richtig gut, teilweise tun sie es etwas pragmatisch. Und vielleicht haben sie sogar noch daraus gelernt, wie das geht. Einzelspieler, die überbordend gut sind. Also es gibt wenig, was ich über Manchester Citys Kader stellen würde. Aber die Front 5 bei Liverpool, das ist sensationell. Was da rumläuft inzwischen, glaube ich, muss ich tatsächlich entscheiden. Lasse ich Schotter oder Firmino draußen? Und dann hat er dann mit Luis Díaz noch jemanden verpflichten können. Der ist ihm ja fast in den Schoß gefallen, weil Tottenham zu lange rumgemacht hat mit der Ablösesumme. Die haben die schön gedrückt und dann hat Liverpool zugegriffen, der einfach derart frischen Wind bringt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Sowohl wenn er von der Bank kommt, als auch, glaube ich, diesem gesamten Club, der ja auch in der Altersstruktur ziemlich ähnlich war, wenn man sich den Kader anguckte. Und dann haben sie mit Conaté jemanden verpflichtet, der voll eingeschlagen hat. Nicht, weil er sofort Stammspieler ist, sondern, was viel wichtiger ist, wann immer er gebraucht wird, zeigt er sofort seine Leistung. Thiago ist gerade auf einem Niveau, das ich so noch nicht gesehen hatte. Und deswegen ist Liverpool wieder extrem ernst zu nehmen im Kampf um die Meisterschaft. Und trotz dessen, dass ich nach wie vor denke, an einem normalen Tag ist City immer noch das beste Team. Aber die zwei, die zählen schon zu den Top-2-3 in Europa, würde ich denken.
Ja, also gerade Luis Diaz, das fand ich absolut bemerkenswert, wie man vom FC Porto kommend einfach so spielen kann, als wäre man schon immer da gewesen bei Liverpool. Keine Stellungsfehler, keine Fehler im Anlaufen. Ich meine, den Fußball, den Jürgen Klopp spielen lässt, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so manchmal überkomplex wie der von Pep Guardiola. Aber dennoch musst du dich da reinfinden. Du musst wissen, was ist meine Rolle in welcher Spielsituation? Wann muss ich jetzt dann den tiefen Lauf machen? Wann muss ich das Spielfeld breit ziehen? Gerade die Außenspiele sind da ja extrem wichtig. Da muss man ja nur mal sich angucken, was mit einem gewissen Trend Alexander Arnaz so passiert ist in den letzten Jahren, warum der auch so eine Rolle spielt, die er spielt bei Liverpool. Und Luis Dias kommt da rein und spielt von Anfang an, als wäre der schon seit zwei Jahren dort. Das war absolut beeindruckend.
Konstant auf dem Temponiveau, das in der Premier League mit Verlaub, ein total anderes ist als in Portugal. Und es scheint so, als könnte der alles in kompletter Intensität absolvieren. Also der Lernprozess, das Stellungsspiel und das alles auf dem Tempo, in dieser Geschwindigkeit auch im Kopf schalten zu müssen, das habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Ohne Transitionen reinzukommen in die Premier League, das habe ich so noch nie gesehen.
Das ist echt, ja, es ist einfach wirklich faszinierend. Würdest du denn sagen, dass sich der Fußball, den Jürgen Klopp spielen lässt, verändert hat im Vergleich eben dann zu dieser Mannschaft von vor zwei Jahren?
Ja, also der hat sich sicherlich schon etwas verändert. Da sind mehr spielerische Elemente drin, mehr Ball halten, je nachdem, wen er spielen lässt. Aber wenn Thiago spielt, das ist ja, glaube ich, es geht ja gar nicht anders, dass das so ist. Im Wesentlichen ist es aber schon noch die Art und Weise, wie er vor zwei Jahren hat spielen lassen, also im Gesamtwesentlichen. Es wird ein bisschen unterschiedlich interpretiert, eben in Ballbesitzphasen beispielsweise, mit Thiago am Ball ist es so, dass noch die Außenverteidiger, vor allen Dingen Trent Alexander-Arnold, das ist ja immer eine gewisse Asymmetrie gewesen, dass die beiden Außenverteidiger nochmal andere Rollen haben. Da hat er vor allen Dingen daran gearbeitet, dass die Innenbahn dann sozusagen vom Achter mehr oder weniger nach innen ziehend interpretiert wird, dass noch mehr überlappen möglich ist. Das sind Details, aber im Grunde genommen hat sich wenig verändert, sondern sie sind einfach wieder auf dem gleichen Gesamtniveau. Er versucht auch immer noch nach wie vor, Mohamed Salah dazu zu bewegen, nicht ausschließlich alleine zu gehen, sondern sich mehr am mannschaftlichen Lauf zu beteiligen. Was aber, glaube ich, auch der hat so eine individuelle Klasse, das ist auch gar nicht immer sinnvoll, dem das zu verbieten. Das sind nach wie vor so die Dinge, an denen er arbeitet. Das sieht man mal besser, mal schlechter, aber im Grunde genommen würde ich nicht sagen, dass sich viele, viele Dinge verändert haben im Vergleich zur Meistersaison.
Das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich, weil man sagt ja, dass man sich im Fußball immer weiterentwickeln muss. Auf jede Entwicklung folgt eine Gegenentwicklung, und die stellen sich dann blank. Aber Liverpool und sicher auch Manchester City, über die wir dann gleich noch ein paar Worte verlieren sollten, die haben sich auf einem solchen Niveau in ihrer Nische breitgemacht, dass dem im modernen Fußball im Grunde kein Kraut gewachsen ist. Also egal, ob du da jetzt ein Atletico dagegen stellst oder ob du da einen Barca dagegen stellst oder ob du mit Pégé irgendwie versuchst, sie übers Tempo zu kriegen. Auf jeden Gegner kann man sich einstellen. Und ich fand, das hat man ganz in beeindruckender Art und Weise von Liverpool in der Champions League gesehen gegen Inter, die ja nun wirklich auch keine schlechte Mannschaft haben, auch wenn es jetzt gerade da in der Serie A nochmal spannender geworden ist, als Inter sich das wünschen würde. Aber im Hinspiel in Mailand, da hat Inter –also ich habe jetzt die Zahl nicht nachrecherchiert, aber gefühlt hat der Inter da 70 Prozent beibesetzt in den ersten zehn Minuten, vielleicht sogar mehr. Und ich hatte aber zu jeder Zeit das Gefühl, naja, Liverpool, die gucken sich das jetzt gerade an. Und dann entscheiden die Spieler in einem kollektiven Bewusstsein fast schon, wie kontern wir die jetzt aus? Wie packen wir die am besten? Und genau so kam es. Inter hatte den Ball, Liverpool hatte die Idee. Und das ist eine Fußballintelligenz, die bei denen auf dem Platz ist. Das ist wirklich herausragend.
Eine Sache habe ich gerade vergessen, weil du Fußballintelligenz sagst, die Abseits-Falle, die sich Klopp hat einfallen lassen, die sucht europaweit komplett seinesgleichen.
Das ist wie Belgien 92, oder? War das nicht damals?
Oder 88? Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ach ja, peinlich. Jetzt wollte ich gerade sagen, wann Belgien die Abseits-Falle eingeführt hat. Gegen Deutschland haben sie dann verloren tatsächlich. Aber vorher sind sie so durch ein Turnier durchgerauscht. Ich google es noch mal hinterher. Und du erzählst, wie die neue Abseits-Falle aussieht.
Die haben nichts Neues erfunden in dem Sinne. Aber sie machen das in einer derartigen Effizienz, dass sie doppelt so viele Abseits-Stellungen und damit ja auch Ballgewinne haben wie der zweite in England. Und die wiederum haben deutlich mehr als der dritte in der Premier League. Und das ist das Erstaunliche, dass Glob irgendwie noch mal alles effizienter gestalten hat können mit dieser Truppe, die ja sowieso überdurchschnittlich spielintelligent ist. Das ist ja, glaube ich, gar keine Frage. Aber daran sieht man auch in den kleinen Details. Ich glaube, du hattest den ja auch schon mal zu Gast, den Einwurf-Coach. Dann haben sie ja mit einem deutschen Unternehmen aus Potsdam beispielsweise arbeiten sie sehr, sehr stark an Visualisierung von Spielsituationen. Also gerade vor dem Elfmeterschießen gegen Chelsea im ersten gewonnenen Pokalfinale ist das ja noch mal zum Thema geworden, dass sie da sehr, sehr stark daran arbeiten. Sie versuchen sozusagen, jedes Department abzudecken auf eine hochmoderne Art und Weise. Und all das macht sich halt total bezahlt. Also, glaube ich, schafft es irgendwie, die Spieler das Beste aus ihnen rauszuquetschen. Das klingt jetzt fast so, als würde er sie dabei nicht mitnehmen. Das möchte ich damit nicht sagen. Sondern die Spieler dürfen sich das ganz oft auch selbst entscheiden. Wollen sie so etwas machen oder nicht? Und sie denken, dass das das Richtige ist. Und dann, glaube ich, ist ja immer ein Prozess wirklich sinnhaft. Und das ist das, was er aus dieser Mannschaft rausholt. Vielleicht waren sie auch nie anders und es waren wirklich nur die verletzten Situationen eines der absoluten Top-Teams.
Die EM 1980 war es natürlich. Horst Rubisch hat ja da dann den Siegtreffer gemacht. Da hat Deutschland im Finale gegen Belgien gewonnen. Und Belgien hat eben die Abseits-Falle damals in den Weltfußball im Grunde hineingebracht. Da sind reihenweise Gegner ins Abseits gegangen. Ich fand das auch deshalb interessant, wie dominant Liverpool bei diesem taktischen Stilmittel ist. Weil wenn man möchte –ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es da einen kausalen Zusammenhang gibt, aber zumindest einen temporären gibt es –mit der Einführung des VLA. Wo diese Entscheidungen, die ja dann häufig auch sehr, sehr knapp sind bei dieser Abseits-Stellung, die Liverpool da heraufbeschwört, die werden eben überprüfbar. Und dadurch kannst du dir sicher sein, wenn wir es gut ausführen, dann wird das auch gesehen. Es ist nicht so, dass der Linienrichter oder der Schiedsrichterassistent irgendwann müde wird, die Fahne zu heben, wo man früher manchmal das Gefühl hatte, dass so ab der 8. Abseits-Position es dem Assistenten zu doof immer zu glauben ist Abseits, er hat seinen Augen vielleicht nicht mehr vertraut. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da einen Zusammenhang gibt, aber das war ein Gedanke, den ich schon ganz oft hatte. Und kurioserweise ist es auf der anderen Seite des Feldes aber auch so, dass Liverpool ganz, ganz häufig auch von ultra-knappen Abseits-Entscheidungen betroffen ist, wenn ihnen Tore weggenommen werden durch den VHR. Also Abseits und Liverpool ist irgendwie eine komplizierte Beziehung, aber eine fruchtbare Beziehung.
Ja, es wäre immer ganz interessant, ich müsste mal gucken, ob es dazu erhobene Daten gibt, wie oft sie Abseits zugesprochen bekommen haben nach Videobeweis. Also sprich, waren ein Tor aberkannt worden. Das müsste ich tatsächlich mal gucken. Das weiß ich gar nicht, soweit habe ich gar nicht gedacht. Da siehst du mal, mein Horizont endet dann an gewissen Stellen, aber Gott sei Dank habe ich dich.
Du hast ja 20 Vereine, auf die ich konzentrieren kann. Ich labere hier nur so ein bisschen rum und verwechsel einfach mal die EM 1992 mit der EM von 1980. Also da würde ich jetzt mal mir gar keine Lorbeeren aufsetzen wollen. Lass uns aber dann an der Stelle noch über Manchester City sprechen. Du hast gesagt, sie haben sich menschliche Wochen geleistet. Wenn man da jetzt mit der deutschen Bille drauf guckt, dann könnte man auch böswillig sagen, naja, das ist halt das klassische Irgendwann-Schaffens, die Menschen im gardiolischen Maschinenfußball nicht mehr zu spielen wie Maschinen. Ist das so einfach gedacht? Gab es noch andere Faktoren? Wie würdest du City bewerten im Vergleich mit Liverpool?
Ja, es wäre ein bisschen einfacher. Also erstens Ruben Diasch spielt, der alles organisiert hinten drin. Das tut natürlich weh. Und dann ist das Muster immer erkennbar bei jedem Premier League-Spiel inzwischen, dass sich der Gegner einfach nur reinstellt. Und da hat City dann genauso wie alle anderen Teams, wenn das wirklich ein Zehnerriegel ist, wie das Southampton zum Beispiel zweimal getan hat in der Saison, dann tut sich City halt auch schwer, ein Tor zu erzielen. Sie erspielen sich die Möglichkeiten, aber dann gibt es halt mal Tage, wo er nicht reinfällt. Es ist auch noch nicht mal so, dass sie arg viel verloren haben. Sie haben sich das gegen Tottenham geleistet. Okay, das passiert irgendwann in dieser Liga, in 29 Spielen, dass man einmal verliert. Und ansonsten waren es halt unentschieden dieser Art, die passiert sind. Ich würde noch nicht großen Abrieb feststellen. Ich glaube, das hat man jetzt auch noch mal in der Champions League gesehen, dass die, die sind schon drüber, über dem Rest Europas an einem normalen Tag. Aber es gibt halt inzwischen diese Machart von kleinen Gegnern, die sich hinten reinstellen und die ihnen dann wirklich –in Crystal Palace war es auch so –die denen einfach verteidigungstechnisch so viel abverlangen. Und dann irgendwann gibt es automatisch mal einen Lauf und dann passiert es halt oder passiert es nicht. Aber das ist keine Krise oder wir sind noch nicht mal in der Nähe von irgendeinem besonderen Abrieb, sondern das ist gerade wieder das, was Guardiola ja in seiner gesamten Zeit als Trainer immer wieder hat feststellen müssen. Für ganz kurze Zeit knackt jemand. Die Art und Weise, wie man gegen sie spielen muss. Ich glaube, das sind die Dinge, an denen er am meisten Spaß hat, weil dann er tüftelt er halt wieder was, um es zu umgehen. Und das werden wir auch in dieser Saison so erleben. Also ich habe nach wie vor, ich bin sehr gespannt auf dieses Spiel, ich glaube, 10. April ist es zwischen Liverpool und City. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es ausgehen wird, weil in dem Spiel traue ich durchaus Liverpool noch zu, dass sie sie schlagen, wenngleich auch da in den letzten Spielen Guardiola immer vorne dran war. Ich würde aber trotzdem nach wie vor denken, dass City immer noch den Ticken besser ist, weil die haben wirklich auf alles eine Antwort. Und es gibt gar nichts, mit dem die nicht umgehen können. Es dauert vielleicht nur manchmal eineinhalb Wochen, aber die muss man, glaube ich, auch so einem Team mal zugestehen.
Ja, also das werden wirklich interessante Wochen. 10. April geht es los mit dem Spiel City gegen Liverpool in Manchester. Das Ganze ist ins Sandwich eingepackt aus den Champions League Spielen. Da spielt Liverpool gegen Benfica und Manchester City tritt gegen Atletico Madrid an. Also Stichworten, Mannschaften, die sich gut einmauern. Könnten wir vielleicht auch nochmal ein Fallbeispiel sehen. Und dann treffen diese beiden Teams aber noch einmal aufeinander, nämlich im FA Cup-Halbfinale auch wieder in Manchester. Also diesen direkten Vergleich, wir werden ihn gleich zweimal bekommen. Einmal wird er –könnte er –die Meisterschaft entscheiden. Einmal wird er zumindest darüber schon mal entscheiden, wer ins Finale des FA Cup einzieht. Und zwischendurch müssen die beiden aber auch noch in der Champions League antreten. Also dieser berühmte heiße April, den wir bei den Top-Mannschaften dann eben immer sehen, er wird auch bei City und bei Liverpool auf jeden Fall zu beobachten sein. Im Grunde, wir müssen so langsam dann die Kurve kriegen, aber ich muss noch über ein emotionales Thema mit dir sprechen, Uli. Und zwar allein für mich emotional. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich den größten Glauben an den Fußball habe, aber es gab noch mal einen Stich in meinem Herz, und das war die Entlassung von Bielsa bei Leeds United. Jetzt springen wir thematisch ein bisschen. Ich fand das –ja, es gibt ja immer Gründe für eine Trainerentlassung, und auch bei Leeds lief es nicht gut. Aber kannst du es nachvollziehen, dass ich das eben aus diesen emotionalen Gründen mit der Geschichte von Leeds United, mit dem, was Marcelo Bielsa für diesen Verein getan hat, indem er sie endlich wieder in die Premier League geführt hat, dass ich damit meine Probleme mit dieser Entlassung hatte?
Die hatte ich auch, und ich glaube alle anderen auch. Weil man hatte das Gefühl, wenn irgendetwas reine Ergebnisse überdauern kann, dann ist es eine Geschichte wie diese von Bielsa und Leeds. Ich hatte genau dieselben Gedankengänge wie du. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich dann mal los sagt von den Gefühlen und sich die Fakten angeguckt hatte, dann kam man schon irgendwie auch zu den Ergebnissen. Einerseits ist das das, was ich an Marcelo Bielsa so sehr geschätzt habe, fast verehrt habe, dass er einfach gesagt hat, ne, auf meine Art, es gibt ja den berühmten Satz, wer den Plan B nimmt, der hat einfach nur nicht genügend Vertrauen in Plan A. Und das ist irgendwie auf eine Weise dumm. Auf eine andere Weise ist es so überzeugend und auch so überzeugend für mich gewesen, dass ich immer gehofft habe, dass Plan A wirklich funktioniert. Aber es gab diese Gegentorflut, die sie bekommen haben, sie sahen wirklich teilweise richtig, richtig schlecht aus. Und da konnte ich es dann schon verstehen, dass sie haben reagieren müssen. Also wenn man sich von allen Emotionen los sagt, dann glaube ich, ist das nachvollziehbar. Aber mir ging es wie dir auch. Das war eine ganz, ganz, ganz besondere Zeit, die es gab. Die war am Ende ja gar nicht so lang. Aber mit diesem Aufstieg, mit der Art und Weise, wie Bielsa das gemacht hat, mit seiner komischen, kautzigen Art und auf der anderen Seite, das hat trotzdem noch einnehmend gewesen. Und das hat so einen Typen wie ihn. Und diese Art und Weise, wie er diesen Verein geführt hat, die gab es ja in unserem Fußballkosmos so gar nicht mehr. Und deswegen hätte man sich, glaube ich, ich habe gar keine andere Stimme gelesen, gar nicht. Und das ist ja sehr, sehr selten. Ich glaube, jeder hätte sich gewünscht, dass es einfach weitergeht.
Bordeaux, Gräute-Fürth, Salah, Nitana und dann schon Leeds United. Das sind die schlechtesten Abwehrreihen, stand heute in Europa. Das ordnet das ein bisschen ein, was du angesprochen hast. Und jetzt hat ja Leeds als Nachfolger von Bielsa jemand bekommen, den wir auch jüngst beobachten konnten in der Bundesliga, nämlich Jesse Marsh wurde der neue Trainer. Allein der Ergebnisse nach hat sich ein bisschen etwas verändert. Man hat jetzt die letzten beiden Partien gewinnen können. Man musste auch dringend Punkte sammeln. Damit hat man jetzt eben sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf die Abstiegsplätze schon mal anhäufen können. Was hat Marsh verändert? Und glaubst du, dass wir aufgrund seines Engagements bei Leeds United mal anders auf ihn blicken werden, als jetzt über diese kurze Episode bei Leipzig, die wir alle mitbekommen haben?
Ja, die glaube ich viel überlagert hat, auch für mich auch. Also ich habe irgendwie eine Art von Sturheit kennengelernt, die ich nicht dachte, bei jemandem so zu sehen. Ich habe mir das auch durch eine Sonne nochmal bestätigen lassen. Das scheint bei Leeds anders zu sein. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe nichts in 90 Minuten gesehen von ihm bislang. Ich bin einfach zeitlich noch nicht dazugekommen. Ich habe es mir immer mal ausschnitteweise angeguckt und habe mir von einem Kollegen immer sagen lassen, wie es lief. Das heißt, alles was ich dir erzähle, ist nur zum Teil richtig oder hat keinen Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit. Es scheint so, als habe er an systematischen Abläufen in der Defensive etwas gearbeitet, arbeiten lassen, also sprich Restverteidigung und dergleichen. Das war ja das große Problem, dass Bielsa so cool ich das fand und so gerne ich es gesehen habe, aber er ließ ja am Ende 1 gegen 1 verteidigen und hat fast Mandeckung gespielt. Das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Und da hat Marsch wohl versucht, so habe ich es mir auch in ein paar Sequenzen in der Scouting-Plattform angeguckt, da hat er wohl versucht, mehr Hilfe herzustellen, also sprich eher im Kollektiv sich zusammenziehen zu lassen. Aber im gesamten dynamischen Prozess, ich müsste dir jetzt Käse erzählen, will ich nicht tun, ich habe sie mir noch nicht anschauen können.
Du kannst ja auch nicht alles sehen, nicht einmal du, lieber Uli. Dann ein aller, aller letztes Thema und dann ist leider diese wunderschöne Sendung schon vorbei. Aber wenn wir bei Leeds sind auf Rang 16, dann müssen wir auch über Everton sprechen, Everton, Everton auf Rang 17. Die haben nämlich nur drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Wattford. Die haben einen sehr bekannten Trainer, nämlich Frank Lampard. Und die haben sehr, sehr viel Unruhe im Umfeld, denn die sind so ein bisschen das umgedrehte ersten Villa. Du hast vorhin gesagt ersten Villa, die können jetzt richtig mal vielleicht oben angreifen und die bleiben ja auch schon jetzt letztlich die letzten Jahre den Top-Six immer ganz gut an den Haken kleben. Bei Everton haben wir einen turbulenten Verlauf der letzten Jahre, der eben jetzt in Abstiegskampf geführt hat, auch wenn man jetzt das letzte Spiel endlich mal wieder gewinnen konnte. Wie kritisch ist da die Situation?
Viel kritischer, als ich es zunächst angenommen habe, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn es ein Äquivalent gibt zum HSV in Deutschland, dann ist Everton, glaube ich, sehr passend. Auch da geht los ein Nullplan hinter diesem Verein. Er ist ein Geldgeber, der will einfach an die Big Six ran, egal wie. Und er denkt, dass er das mit großen Namen schaffen kann. Da ist überhaupt keine Kontinuität auf dem Trainerposten. Inzwischen auch nicht mehr auf dem Direktor-Football-Posten. Marcel Brands entlassen worden. Dann gab es diese etwas unwürdige Geschichte mit Rafa Benitez, den, glaube ich, die Fans nicht im Ansatz gemocht haben. Sie haben ihm halbwegs verziehen, als es zu Beginn der Saison ganz gut losging. Dann sind die Ergebnisse ausgeblieben. In der Woche, in der Benitez entlassen wurden, ist der Publikumsliebling verkauft worden, Luca Dini, weil er Streit hatte mit Benitez. Am Ende der Woche wird Benitez entlassen. Lampard hat ein völlig dysfunktionales Team übernommen und hat Lampards Sachen gemacht, nämlich einfach mal freudig durchgewechselt, sowohl was das System betrifft als auch was das Personal betrifft. Das sieht man auch auf Platz, die totale Verunsicherung. Jetzt haben sie das eine nachholspiel gegen Brighton zu Zehnt gewonnen. Das war aber ein Hail Mary Angriff und nichts anderes. Das war auch Katastrophe, dieses Spiel, das hab ich gemacht. Und ja, hat ihnen jetzt Luft verschafft. Am nächsten Wochenende im FA Cup sind sie aber wieder mit vier Baden gegen Crystal Palace gegangen, die mit Verlaub ein paar Dinge richtig gut machen, aber jetzt nicht den aller ansehnlichsten Angriffsfußball spielen. Wir haben ja einfach nur zu Ende gekontert. Ich hab echt Angst um Everton. Ich fürchte oder je nachdem, wie man es sehen will, denke, dass es sich drei Schwächere finden werden, weil Everton einfach individuelle Qualität im Kader hat. Aber alles andere ist gerade nicht zu ausreichen. Die müssen sich ernsthaft Gedanken machen im Sommer, wie sie den ganzen Laden aufstellen. Und da gibt es wirklich, wirklich einiges zu tun.
Uli, jetzt ist das passiert, was ich befürchtet habe. Wir haben so schön ein Format der Ligatur eingeführt, in dem wir über alle großen europäischen Ligen –Ausnahme der Bundesliga –sprechen. Und jetzt machen wir mal wieder so eine alte Retro-Folge. Und ich lerne wieder dieses alte Format zu schätzen, weil man einfach ein bisschen mehr Zeit hat, weil wir jetzt so viele Themen abhandeln konnten und die ja trotzdem nicht am Ende sind. Wir mussten jetzt ja trotzdem Vereine weglassen, Themen weglassen und so weiter. Was ich aber sagen kann, ist, dass es wie immer ganz, ganz großen Spaß gemacht hat. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank, lieber Uli.
Mir hat es auch viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich zu hören. Ihr könnt Uli Hebel hören bei Sky. Ihr könnt ihn hören bei Click & Rush. Das wisst ihr inzwischen hoffentlich alle schon. Ansonsten solltet ihr immer eure Hörgewohnheiten hinterfragen. Und ihr könnt ihn auch bei The Zone sehen. Uli ist ein Wanderer zwischen den Welten und ein ganz hervorragender Podcast-Gast. Ich danke dir, Uli, und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist weiter paywall-werbe- und sponsor-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de gibt es jetzt auch endlich die neue Rasenfunktasse. Auch wenn ihr unser Merchandise kauft, der immer fair und möglichst lokal hergestellt ist, könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Die Tasse zum Beispiel kommt aus Deutschland, wird von Hand gefertigt und ja, vielleicht gefällt's euch ja auch. Schaut's euch an, kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Wir hören uns bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk.